here in the lobby of the headquarters of
Ramsey solutions Jonathan and Janelle
are joining us
hey guys how are ya are you happy
Thanksgiving Eve - yeah
so you're here to do a debt-free scream
yes sir yeah where are you from wait if
you're in Nashville we're neighbours
then okay very cool before we get
started what do you thankful for
husband wife we've been blessed with
great relationships very cool good okay
how much dad have you guys paid off one
hundred and twenty two thousand give or
take I love it and how long did that
take you four years four years excellent
making what kind of money we started at
about seventy-five thousand and got up
to 125 or back around 100 roughly okay
cool what do you guys do for a living I
write software and she sells clothing
and and the mama that works very cool
what kind of debt was one hundred and
twenty two thousand dollars would you
people buy college she bought college
and I bought a lot of stupid stuff so
what kind of stupid stuff
um card debt personal loans doctor bill
credit card
Abed turnaround pretty much everything
you guys are kind of normal yeah well it
was me it was me I did it those before
we got married so okay I did how much of
the 122 was the student lunch Oh
probably ninety okay so a bunch of a lot
okay cool um what's your degree in a
month computer science and I have a
bachelor's in business and a master's in
counseling Oh excellent very good okay
cool so tell me the story what happened
four years ago that puts you guys on
this journey
well our anniversary is actually
tomorrow so yeah 40 anniversary so I met
her and wanted to buy an engagement ring
and looked around and I didn't have any
money and so then I figured I should
probably get on top of that especially
if I'm gonna be a husband and a father
so she was already good with her money
I was stupid my money so so yeah so that
give or take 90 grand worth of student
loan debt
smarter yeah buy an engagement ring was
what really set me off and then we both
agree that we want it to be good
stewards what we were given so huh
we started started on your plane okay so
you how'd you get the money for the
engagement ring
I saved I stopped being stupid okay so
build up your slaves and merge goal is
for a start anything we got to get the
ring done yep and then you you guys get
married and you decide to work on this
together tell me how that all worked
what happened there
it was great well we we had our wedding
and so we wanted to cash flow that and
so that was I think that was probably
the biggest thing that got us started
was having to plane that because she had
her dreams for wedding I obviously
wanted to serve those while still being
good stewards of our money and so so
that was a good good test of learning
how to say no to some things that seemed
really important but still in focusing
on the relationships that was our big
thing so so when we realized was really
about relationships and not about the
big thing at the wedding that helped
kind of set a path or how we spent money
for the family marry it's what you spend
on the wedding pray about 10 or 15 yeah
it was a good wedding oh it was awesome
we spent a week in Destin with friends
and family it was awesome we love each
house yeah right great okay
and cash flow did all good very cool
good so that kind of started the whole
process was there good full disclosure
you both knew what you were getting into
money-wise yes yes
okay great we've been on the same page
we've been very blessed okay she get
married you paid for the wedding and
then you start chipping away at this
debt tell me how that worked what
happened you come home from the
honeymoon we say okay tom game on yeah
you know I think once we decided and we
just decided we we bought your CDs and I
was familiar with most of it but we
listened to him together make sure we're
on the same page and and make sure she
was really inspired because I was
already you know I was really ready to
do it and then from there was just every
month the bills come in and you pay them
and and you just you just do it what
once it was decided in my mind it was
kind of done and just took time to get
done okay so Janelle he gets he decides
he's gonna wake up and the ring wakes
him up and then we do the wedding and
now he's got the CDs and making you
listen to Dave Ramsey and all this kind
of stuff so what were you doing I mean
we're using are you on board or we found
like
back a little bit I don't know I was I
was a saver no it was I think the
hardest thing for me before marrying him
well in and after was believing that it
would actually happen that there would
come this day that we're celebrating the
day that were actually dead free so you
were during the average month you were
taking care of money
ignoring the $90,000 monster in the
closet well you were just kind of that
you're kind of personal I mean you I
mean you were saying I didn't think I
could ever get there now you're saying
you thought you could get there well her
income was smaller than mine and so that
was the thing right so I mean you didn't
think you would ever get there you said
and then you said I thought I could get
there that was the struggle as far as
believing that again will we ever be
here you know guess we're finally here
yeah so now that you're here was it
harder easier than you thought when you
started there were definitely times when
it was hard because you had to say no to
things yeah hey let's go out to eat or
let's go on this vacation
sorry guys we're getting out of debt and
people would kind of make fun of you Oh
dead free people you sure it's like it's
worth it yeah I don't think it was
harder for me I think was just like I
said once it was set that we were doing
it it was just kind of like all right
let's come in and you just kind of gotta
be patient
so it was it was hardly impatient that
you look at the number and it doesn't go
down as fast so I was we did you just
flowchart at it and you're just walking
right into the flow thinking ding I can
tell you're developer I'm cool very cool
congratulations how's it feel now oh
it's it's awesome we look at our budget
now and the question is not what that
we're gonna pay off its who we're gonna
give to and that's really fun yeah
that's really good very cool in it for
you seeing her now she's doing her
business and seeing her flourish his
really makes it worth it yeah I predict
the business goes Zoom Zoom now yeah
it's yeah yeah I imagine it well because
if most businesses when you get out of
data it frees you up frees your brain up
you in realize you were using the part
of your brain to just worry and then
when that parts not used anymore it
frees up your creativity and your energy
and everything else it's pretty cool
very neat stuff you guys so what do you
tell those people who used to make fun
of you when they now ask how did you do
that how did you get out of that
that's the plan i agreeing yeah agree
and it's meeting agreement it's worth
yeah when you know it's the biggest
fight you had you know we just don't I
told friends like I don't think we've
ever had a single fight about money just
because we agreed you know like one
thing that we say that you said it's
right it's agreeing about your dreams
right yeah we sit down and we say this
is what we want as a family just as
believers what does that mean and then
your money okay your morning points of
that right so so we just agreed on those
things and so so that's a big deal to be
in unity yeah it's a very big deal so
but we just tell them it's worth it it
is worth it and and if you if you really
believe that you're a steward of God's
money then if you think that way you're
just like all right what am i doing okay
well I just you know I spent $500 at the
casino I don't think that wasn't God's
plan for that money so yeah and we call
that fun yeah congratulations you two
very very well done Jonathan and Janelle
from right here in Nashville a hundred
and twenty two thousand dollars paid off
in four years making 75 to 125 then to a
hundred count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
all right love it love it love it those
of you listening on radio didn't get the
full picture they handed in their
beautiful baby just as I got ready to
scream we're debt-free cute cute cute
that'll give you some motivation right
there too